已经有人唱红脸了，
我就唱白脸了，
为了能够平息这个事情，
我是愿意跟你先离的，
愿意让他上位的，
因为你知道他是这个性格，
他将来能干出什么事儿还未必呢，
所以财产的事情还是要先保护孩子的利益，
我发现我老公出轨了，
并且我也有证据在手，
我之前就有怀疑，
但是他不承认，
我拿到证据以后，
他就说我的要求是我要离，
因为我们有两个孩子嘛，
他说因为孩子还小，
要叫我怎样考虑孩子各种，
他就说他不离，
他说他会去处理好，
去解决好，
我也没有表态，
因为发现这个事情是这个月的8号，
他说他已经处理了所有的联系方式，
拉黑删除，
已经没有再联系了，
结果昨天我又发现其实他们还有联系的，
他就说因为对方三姐一直在来找他，
纠缠他，
因为我们两个是体制内的工作，
因为我之前不想把事情搞得太大，
一个是我们双方的工作也好，
孩子的脸面也好，
我还是有点顾忌的，
我只是想着我们把这个事情解决了，
结果昨天发现他依然还和对方有联系，
但是他给我的解释是说因为一直在来纠缠他，
他要去。
处理这些事情，
他说让我相信他，
他会解决好，
但是我现在他说的任何话我是不信的，
我的要求就是离，
但是他不离，
我说那不离也行，
叫他签一个婚恋协议，
我们现在是有两个房子，
一个是有贷款，
一个是全款，
有贷款的那个贷款是每个月是他在还，
我也不想说去跟他争取我这边的任何，
我不想去，
我只想说把所有的我能留给孩子的东西，
我都留给他，
留给两个孩子，
所以我婚前协议我就跟他讲，
孩子一人一套存款什么的，
必须给孩子存到孩子的账户里面去，
孩子的抚养权给他，
但是我们共同抚养，
因为我们小县城嘛，
很近就不远，
所以我随时可以照顾得到，
但是他又觉得说可能协议的内容他可能不太接受，
我现在我的想法，
我还是要离，
但是我现在要怎么利益最大化？
利益最大化手上已经有着实的证据了，
他的工作又是体制内，
那谈判是利益最大化，
但是我昨天晚上我跟他谈了两套房子，
孩子一人一套，
存款全部存到孩子的账户里面去，
我还有一个问题，
如果说我把孩子的抚养权给他这些。
边孩子名下的所有东西，
这个是有技巧的，
如果说房子放在了孩子的名下，
为了避免出现那种一个人把这个房子卖掉的情况，
可以设居住权，
或者可以把房子登记为是按份共有，
比如说孩子占98%，
你和你的老公一人占1%，
这样谁也卖不掉，
谁要想买这个房子的话，
都得要对方签字，
不签字谁也卖不掉，
就是可以通过法律技巧来解决掉的，
那就是除了这些，
如果说谈判不成的话，
要撕破脸的话，
我应该怎么做？
先找一轮上到单位去找一轮吓唬吓唬他，
昨天三姐还给我发了信息，
已经找到我这儿来了，
之前三姐在我8号发现之前的前面几天还去加了我婆婆的微信，
让我婆婆知道了这件事情，
我就觉得这个三姐不简单，
因为她是没有正经工作的，
她可能拿捏了我们两个是体制内的，
可能不会把事情搞太大。
我估计三姐的心里她是想上位的，
他也觉得我老公可能不敢把事情闹到单位里面去，
现在是我感觉我老公被他拿捏了，
如果说三姐得不到他想要的，
他可能有跟我老公说要。
到到我老公的单位去，
现在的情况可能不是我要搞到他单位去，
可能三姐会搞到他单位去，
如果搞到他单位去，
影响的是他的晋升，
也不至于到开除那个程度吧，
我具体的会到哪一个什么程度，
我就不太清楚，
那如果是这样的话，
我就唱白脸了，
已经有人唱红脸了，
为了能够平息这个事情，
我是愿意跟你先离的，
愿意让他上位的，
但是我们这些财产的话，
因为你知道他是这个性格，
他将来能干出什么事还未必呢，
所以财产的事情的还是要先保护孩子的利益，
如果有人唱红脸的话，
那我就唱白脸，
我就以帮助他平息化解的这样一个姿态出现，
句句不提我的利益，
句句都提你的工作，
句句都提你的前途，
就记这个，
我昨天也跟他讲，
我说这个三姐是不简单的，
只要没有达到她的目的，
她可能会你看她找到我婆婆那里去，
找到我这儿来，
下一步有可能如果她达不到她的目的的话，
有可能会搞到单位去，
那其实你也有好处，
这个好处就是我可以不用跟我老公去撕破脸来争这些利益吗？
是，
那如果说是走法律程序的话。
我这边需要做些什么准备，
你是说如果他始终是不同意分开是吧？
对，
现在他来反过来道德绑架我，
他说现在孩子还小，
如果说能分开，
会给孩子带来怎么样的伤害，
因为他也是单亲家庭嘛，
他就说他是这样经历过的，
他就说怎么样，
对孩子的伤害有多大，
怎么样，
那我来考虑孩子，
我说我告诉他，
你现在反过来道德绑架我，
但凡你当初在做这个事情的时候，
你考虑一点孩子都不至于这样子，
回答的特别好，
说的特别好，
不要被任何人PUUA或的孩子，
今天有一个破碎的家庭，
不是我造成的，
是你造成的，
你要永远记住这一点，
是的，
我也这样跟他讲的，
但是他现在反正反过来绑架我说我不考虑孩子，
现在孩子还小，
他让我说等孩子稍微大一点，
因为我小的那个老二才昨天刚满4岁，
他说让他稍微再大一点，
让他上小学啊，
怎么样的？
我说最难的时候你留下我当免费的保姆，
好，
孩子大了，
轻松了，
那我可以走了，
是吧？
我就这样反问他的，
我跟他提的这个婚恋协议，
他可能难以接受，
现在还没有给我正式的答复，
说要怎么样。
我说你如果你能接受，
那就签，
如果你不能接受，
我也不勉强你，
那就按照我的。
打发孩子，
那就离婚，
该怎么分就怎么分，
该怎么留给孩子就留给孩子，
你这个态度没有任何问题，
有理有据，
而且头脑非常清晰，
就该这样，
那我现在就等他这边答复呗，
如果说他觉得那个协议他签不了，
或者说是更进一步，
我们把这个事情闹大了以后，
我要去走法律程序的话，
请律师帮助我们，
还是我应该怎么走，
走法律程序的话，
我建议还是请个律师起诉，
还是请个律师，
自己会减少很多那种琐碎的麻烦，
因为我本来这件事情上，
我在情感上就已经很负面的情绪了，
如果我还要去整天起草那个，
查这个查那个，
就会更放大我的那种负面的情绪，
我还不如说花钱买个痛快，
花钱买个茶，
帮我去做这些麻烦的事情，
这样我的心情情绪会好很多，
我是这么考虑问题的，
我觉得花这个钱就是买一个，
我别操心这个事儿，
而且也是买一个态度，
当他发现我都已经花钱请了律师，
他也是一个信号和态度，
对，
如果说我们把存款存到孩子的账户里边去的话，
这房子像你刚才说的，
按你说的这种做，
但是存款在孩子的账户里边，
因为他们现在未成年嘛，
那如果抚养权给他的话，
他有没有权，
有可能这个钱有可能。
我觉得如果是存的话，
呃，
有的银行其实它有一个共管账户这个概念，
有一部分银行有，
就共管账户是比较那个什么的，
就必须你们两个人才能把这个钱动了行，
因为我看评论区我说怎么能把孩子给男方嘛，
其实之前他可能是拿捏我的，
因为我对孩子的爱也好，
付出也好，
肯定是我比他更多，
因为他的工作的关系，
他会很忙，
经常不着家嘛的，
他可能觉得就算我发现这个事情，
但是我肯定会把孩子带走，
但是为什么说我要把孩子坚决的给他，
那就是因为工资也好，
或者是任何东西也好，
就是他那边能力稍微好一点，
对，
如果是综合考虑的，
各方面的考虑下来，
我就觉得因为我们也很近，
如果要照顾也可以照顾到，
对，
离得近的好，
我觉得你的做法没有任何问题啊，
你不愧是在直播间，
应该蹲的时间也不短，
现在的做法没有任何问题，
好关系，
我觉得没什么问题了，
好好，
你有没有发现人真的很奇怪，
他自己在外面乱搞的时候，
他没有想过对孩子会有什么负面的影响，
等到事情东窗事发了，
他犯错误，
你发现他在外面乱搞，
你反正变成了那个罪人，
有没有经历过的，
有没有同感呢？
记得点赞关注哦。